[ __ ] what happened your mozzarella
sticks pilot didn't get picked up hey
what's going on everybody four first we
feast I'm Sean Evans and you're watching
hot ones the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today I'm joined
by comedian Jeff Ross he's hosting a
four-part Thunderdome style
insult comedy tournament I guess you
could call her Jeff Ross presents roast
battle run can catch an on Comedy
Central Jeff welcome to the show thanks
Sean
thanks for having me on your show what's
going through your head right now what
do you feeling hunger hunger that's a
good thing one of my favorite comedy
club is the Comedy Cellar in New York
and right now their kitchen is being
rebuilt so there's no wings
so I'm cramming wings well this might be
one of the worst meals you've ever had
in your life
so this first wing is sriracha you know
about sriracha right yeah a little bit
it's no big deal
we're gonna warm them up a little bit
well we didn't want to waste your time
Jeff you know what I mean like we
respect your time so doesn't love cold
wings until they afternoon you know a
lot of people know you from the roasts
and somebody who always sticks out in my
mind he's a mainstay there too is Shaq
and Shaq's interesting because through
this job I found that interviewing
athletes isn't always so much fun for me
Shaq seems to get jokes is that just
something that I'm perceiving when I
watch these things on TV or is Shaq just
kind of different than some of the other
athlete from the shocks a comedian
shocks many things but he's also a
comedian who gets it has a great
delivery he's a good target at a roast
and he's funny I was really nervous one
of my first roasts was in Las Vegas for
Shaq's charity a long time ago like 2001
or two and I had some crazy jokes I
didn't really have the reputation I have
now and I met Shaq who had invited me to
the show and I said Shaq you know
athletes don't always have a great sense
of humor are you and your friends gonna
be okay with some of these hard-hitting
jokes he said no one ever told me to
hold back on the basketball court I
would never tell you to hold back at a
roast we've been friends ever since he's
a champion and a true champion has a
sense of humor about themselves good
wings so far the questions are hotter
than the wings you once wrote that being
a comic is like having a backstage pass
to the world one of the most interesting
places that that backstage pass took you
to was a County Jail in Texas right
where you roasted many of the inmates I
wonder when you think back on that day
what sorts of things stick out to you oh
my goodness nerves they had never had
that many inmates in one room before and
now you have the different gangs the
white supremacists in the same room as
the
Mexican gangbangers they're eyeing each
other but they're all behaved for a
month in order to get into my show that
was the cover charge so it was a way to
bring people together how did that
experience if at all change or affect
the way you think about the criminal
justice system America I feel lucky that
I never got caught doing anything too
bad right because I don't know if I
would have survived it's scary in there
and made me realize we lock a lot of
people up for dumb [ __ ] I wanted it to
work on two levels I wanted to make
those people that were locked up laughs
and I also wanted to make us at home go
oh that's funny but I also learned a
little something about people in jail I
wanted to humanize the inmates did you
see how I did that those go at the same
time yeah synergy it's the it's the
wings Tapatio why do you get drumsticks
and I get these [ __ ] you have a
drumstick there or you know one I'll
never get to you do a lot of shows
overseas you a lot of USO shows I
understand that yet a hotel with a
mortar attack yeah was that the biggest
[ __ ] your pants moment that you ever had
overseas or was there something no the
biggest [ __ ] my pants moment was when we
had to go back to that hotel and sleep
there that night because even though it
was more turd it was still the safest
place in the Baghdad green zone at the
time Wow
so that next night was scarier but it
did you know he had three floors up was
all blown out no I didn't sleep at all
set up all night trying to sleep but
eventually got so dehydrated that I had
to go to the
really yeah I was really nerve-wracking
and I didn't have any ambien I couldn't
drank or smoked any you know so you were
just what the [ __ ]
talking about a backstage pass to the
world I as a comedian to go to a war
zone and I obviously had a ticket out
but hats off to those people overseas
cheers Cheers
so I know that you love New York City
yeah if the apocalypse were to happen
let's say next week and you only had a
day in New York City we're go see
Hamilton again you'd go see Hamill i sat
in I went last week they said the star
of the show it was last week and you had
to see it so my buddy and I went to
stump up and got last row tickets and my
seats were so bad from where I was
sitting it looked like Hamilton was
played by a Puerto Rican guy where would
you eat where would I eat I probably
needed a Friars Club the Friars and see
my friends I'd have some chicken salad
or some chow mein I'd see the comedian
hang out and have some end of the world
camaraderie that's a good way to go out
ready to move on yeah what do you think
hot sauce is good what's the club hot
ones really let's just spend five
minutes trying to think of that name hot
one I've seen hostage videos with a
bigger budget and better food okay so
when you went on tour with Charlie Sheen
here's how I understood your Bowl and
you can tell me to what extent them
right on this or what it's not I'm wrong
yes okay so from what I understand what
Charlie Sheen was doing this tour was
during that sort of tiger blood era
right yeah and he's doing this stage
show and from what I understand it was
such a crazy show that there were like
open revolts in the audience while the
show was going on so he tapped you as
kind of a bullpen relief pitcher guy to
come out when things get hairy and sort
of settled down the crowd is that fairly
accurate it was a fascinating time he'd
go onstage you didn't have much
show or the show he wrote he wasn't
committing to and yeah people are
yelling out for refunds and it was
getting really weird and he kind of
likes the confrontation so I think he
was kind of rising up to that and
digging the excitement of all that going
on but he also knew that it wasn't
enough for show their charge that much
money
here's trying
I said all I want to do is be able to
say whatever I want and I want to have
mat-su kind of podium never like what
I'm like yeah no that's what I need and
they flew me out and I walk out and I'm
on the side and Charlie's manager she's
trying to push me out as the crowd gets
rowdy or in rowdy Aires 20 minutes into
the show 30 minutes into the show you
know and finally I just wait til it's
just literally charlie is handing out
$100 bills to people who are running up
from the rafters trying to get a refund
but that in a weird way is sort of
something that I would pay big money to
attend the show flying off the rails is
kind of better than any show you could
ever scratch if Trump was handing out
$100 bills to anybody who disagreed with
him I'd have to watch like you would
have to have to go
did I pay you to do these no but they
don't pay us to do it all this product
placement is free maybe we sell a couple
bottles I you guys sell your hot sauce
in the same bottles that they do urine
samples of my proctologist
this is High River rogue all right hmm I
River Road I like it
you do yeah not many people do it's kind
of tasty right Arthur roast battle
yeah and roasting in general to me it
shares a lot of parallels with rap
battling or diss tracks have you ever
thought about that or do you see the
same sort of parallels that's just human
nature we love to take the big guy down
I would love to prove ourselves you know
wit versus being able to take a joke
when we roast battle the competitors the
Roasters they spend days if not weeks
going to battle researching somebody
sometimes the battle is we'll have lunch
and talk about what they want to go
after on each other and they really
coordinated so yeah this to me is about
roasting little different things or rat
battling this is like Fight Club for
comedians right you kind of have to see
it to believe it do you get kind of
chills when you hit a punch line just
right the whole place goes crazy this is
no greater feeling it's like
I was a kid seeing Bucky Dent on the
Yankees hit that homerun at the bottom
of the ninth you never thought it would
happen and then BOOM suddenly you're
made from that moment on what is it like
when yeah when you hit up my job when
you hit it just right when you snap just
right you're king of the world it's like
better than food it's better than sex
you just you [ __ ] walk off that's I'm
so you can saw POTUS do it at the
Washington Correspondents Dinner you
know a lot of people give the president
credit for being a legitimately funny
politician which you don't often see do
you see the same thing when you watch
him at the White House Correspondents
Dinner do you see a guy that moves just
a little bit differently yeah I feel
like he's way more poised than even some
of the comedian's that have to go on
after him he's hilarious he could have
been a writer it could've been it
probably could have been a comedian yeah
it's fun to see that because if we don't
laugh we cry life is tough I feel like
DJ Khaled dropping some philosophy now
the only difference with me is I'll whip
the [ __ ] door off ripped off his
hinges that puts engines
like that
any [ __ ] what 100% pain any [ __ ] whoa
that was hard as [ __ ] Jeff in your
memory what do you think is the meanest
thing you've ever said to someone's face
and how did they react oh my god I once
told Courtney loved she looked worse
than Kurt Cobain rememberable years
after he shot himself in the head how
did she react to that
she went and then she saw that everybody
was laughing and she looked at Pam
Anderson who was invited her there and
they kind of locked eyes and they both
gasp and then they laughed and then
within ten minutes Courtney was
pretending to blow me during the
commercial breaks so she didn't take it
too hard now and the next day apparently
she checked herself in a rehab so
roasting saves lives kind of like this
show the human side of a person by
watching them get teary-eyed all right
so this is number eight this is the bomb
beyond insanity hot sauce I know that
you're a big NBA fan since you're the
roastmaster I think it's only fair that
I showed you some NBA style pics piece
of wings are all should holy [ __ ]
oh my body is starting to reject us I
want to show you some NBA style pics
some of these outfits you might like
some of them you don't like Dwyane Wade
here he's great
Dwyane Wade crater uh sir great dresser
what do you think of that scene ah looks
like it's made out of three Kevin Hart
suits
Russell Westbrook over here [ __ ] no
comment
can't talk Oh Amari I think he's kind of
killing this one what do you think I
can't help you all my brain function is
going towards keeping my composure
LeBron I've never heard of him can you
rank these yeah hot mild hottest burning
[ __ ] dude
Jeb how you feeling Oh slow it down
chill man chill for a sec I'm gonna bite
into that I don't think I can
I want to taste them but I know my eyes
are gonna pop out of my head
you want to tap out you can always tap
out Jeff that's my guy right there I'll
do this
Jeff love it baby came prepared this is
mad dog 357
who do you have any advice for people
giving wedding toasts i'mjust wedding
out of my nose time I go to a wedding
there's always the guy giving the toast
and I can tell any Google wedding toasts
how to and it's always the same form how
are you still talking all the advice
that's out there sucks
you seem like a neat guy with unique
perspective that could offer some good
advice yes I speak from the heart
don't say [ __ ] good and keep it short
keep it short and the big is no
17-minute nobody gives a [ __ ] know
Milton Berle once told me after my first
roast they only remember the home runs
tighten that up
leave them what more Jeff how you feel
center yourself it's tradition around
here to dab the last wing but you are in
a tough spot you don't have to get if
you don't want to i'd add the last wing
ah I was kind of a big ass yeah what are
you saying there's nothing on that
there's stuff on it but sometimes we go
an extra mile on the last one Jeff you
don't want to you only have to it's not
a peer pressure Wow
so what I do is I take it fresh out the
bottle so I'm gonna dab your dinner okay
that's good for me because I'm a big ass
damn here we go oh now that you know a
little bit about me and a little bit
about our show maybe you just you roast
me you roast the show while you fight
the hot sauce are you ready to do this
Allah Akbar whoo
first of all I'm not going to boast your
show because this isn't a show not sure
what this is
just look people watch while there are
other shits downloading [ __ ] what have
your mozzarella sticks pilot didn't get
picked up had a great time in thank you
Jeff Jeff oh great work you made it
through and you know it's one of these
shows are you roast in the show or is
the show roast in you is up for debate
like you made it through you look great
floor is yours 30-second plug let the
people know what you got going on in
your life
woof listen [ __ ] if you think
this is the hottest show you're on roast
battle no-holds-barred comedy roasting
tournament the meanest [ __ ] all
over the world five different countries
are all meeting a Montreal to find out
who rules the roast
you